hey guys Pete here today I'm gonna do a
Westworld season 3 episode 4 preview
slash trailer breakdown the trailers
they've been putting out don't have a
lot in them but they did put out a ton
of trailers before the season came out
so we've actually seen a lot of this
stuff already with more context spoiler
warning this will contain spoilers and
speculation about everything that's out
there everything that's happened in West
world up into this point so if you're
not caught up and you don't want to
speculate about what's going to happen
then this video won't be for you the
title of episode 4 is the mother of
exiles and the description is just the
truth doesn't always set you free the
voice-over is a conversation between
Dolores and William or the man in black
and I'm guessing that this will focus on
him in the way that the last episode
focused on hail Dolores did say to the
host consciousness that's inside the
hail host body which I'm just gonna call
it hail or Charlotte to make things
easier that they were gonna have to
visit an old friend and I assume that
they were referring to the man in black
the trailer opens with a shot from
across the water of a building at night
we hear Dolores say I guess there's some
justice after all the building is not
one that I recognize it's not one of the
buildings from the del O's headquarters
that we've seen Charlotte at as far as I
can tell but it could be related to them
it has a kind of look like that we hear
Dolores a prisoner of your own sins and
we get what is probably the most
interesting shot of the trailer it's a
shot of a boy looking at a nuclear
explosion from a field there's a dead
deer next to him
there's a vehicle off in the distance
and this likely ties into the preseason
trailer where we learned that there was
a thermonuclear incident that happened
in Paris in 2025 it's hard to see much
of what's going on with the character
who's standing here we do have a new
main character who's French Ciroc but
I'm not sure the ages would add up here
if this is supposed to be a young boy
this would be in 2025 so only a couple
decades prior to where we're at
on the story and Ciroc looks like he's
in his 50s
either way this could be a back story a
flashback and if I had to guess I would
guess that this is this plays into why
they developed Rahab um and what they
were trying to do they're trying to
bring order and cut down on the chaos
and the senseless destruction and Wars
and things that human beings seem to be
fond of starting and getting into so
that seems like it's probably related to
that in some way after that we see
Williams house there's holes in the
drapes with light shining through
they could be bullet holes he could be
shooting the place up there could be
shots being fired from outside into the
windows not exactly sure but the whole
place looks wrecked we hear Dolores say
you still don't understand who you are
and we see Williams standing barefoot in
the mess with glass on the floor we see
his reflection in a large mirror and
he's holding a handgun now in the weeks
ahead trailer that came out after
episode one we saw him with the same
clothes the same handgun coming out of a
bathtub all of this should be connected
and then we have a closer shot here and
his feet in the broken glass with all of
the trash and things laying on the floor
the man in black responds I know who I
am and we see a shot of him in a
different mirror after that we see this
masquerade party we see the guests are
all wearing masks there's some people up
on platforms they're not wearing masks
they look like they're wearing sexy
clothes and the platforms make them look
like they're on display for the party
goers based on other trailers I think
this is where Caleb and Dolores
approached Liam jr. again from the when
Caleb met Dolores trailer we saw them in
masks at this party so we know it's
related to their side of the story
rather than one of the other ones and we
saw Caleb come up and say I'm with her
or they're wearing the same clothes and
he was approaching Liam we have a shot
of the man in black bent over with a
bright light behind him it looks like
there is light shining on him that's
coming through one of those holes in the
drapes not sure what's going on with the
light behind him
Lloris says if any of this was your
choice and there's a pause and she
finishes that with well you already know
we see another shot of the party we see
a band they're wearing masks and that
cuts back to a clear shot of the man in
blacks face and we see him start
screaming her saying if any of this was
your choice is interesting to me because
it kind of ties into them what we saw at
the end of last season that part that
takes place in the distant future the
man in black seems to want to believe
that he has free will but he has this
problem that he killed his daughter in
the park so that he would also get some
kind of relief out of that he inevitable
the universe being deterministic in the
sense that he did that because he had to
do that not because he made the wrong
choices and it led to her death after
that we see these criminal types outside
a warehouse this is related to Mei Baz
we saw her approach them in a previous
trailer it looks like they're shipping
containers in the background that have
Chinese characters on them there's
pallets on the ground nothing to tell us
why these guys are important like I said
they look like criminals because they're
armed something made does seems to make
them shoot each other perhaps or
something like that it's hard to say we
see it from a different angle in the
weeks ahead trailer and all we can see
for sure is that they're falling and
they're firing their guns off above them
as they go down we see a close-up of
Mays face her eyes light up briefly it's
probably the reflection of those men
firing off their guns this is just a
short shot of Maeve in this dark red
colored dress we saw more in the weeks
ahead trailer she was talking to Ciroc
while wearing it and she says the line
who did she put inside you is that you
in there Teddy she's most likely saying
it to the Connells character that
trailer had it cut so it made you think
that she was saying it to Hale but now
we know that was Dolores talking to Hale
and this is probably her talking to
Connells which was sort of cut all
together there's another shot of William
he says I know who the [ __ ] I am which
is the end of the trailer and this shot
of him is likely right before he shoots
the mirror in the other trailer so the
big deal here is
that we are gonna be spending time with
the man in black he doesn't look like
he's doing so well it sounds like when
Charlotte went to visit him that Dolores
came along she seems to enjoy finding
him in this situation
I'm guessing they need to get him to get
his [ __ ] together because they need help
to stop Ciroc from taking over Delos and
he probably looks like this because he
did kill his daughter but there may be
more going on as well there are a lot of
mirrors in his shots the currently
popular idea on reddit anyways is that
all these references to mirrors are a
hint towards a mirror world which
Dolores mentioned it's definitely
possible there is a lot of references
I'm just kind of at the point of like
how does that make this story better I
can see what people are saying as far as
why they think that might be the case
but if you compare it to two timelines
in the first season that was a neat
twist because you know Dolores didn't
age so we saw one character at two
different times interacting with the
same character the host I'm not sure
what would be so exciting about having a
simulated world or a mirror world like
there has to be something better to it
than just that it exists I haven't read
anything really interesting as far as
that yet so I'm still just waiting to
see where they're going to take that
idea I kind of feel the same way about
the Hale reveal at this point too like I
see that it's supposed to be the big
mystery but I'm not sure why any of the
characters it might be make it for an
exciting twist like I think there's
probably something more to it it could
be this idea that there's multiple
versions of Dolores that's a twist
whereas if it just turns out to be
Abernathy or some other host it's not
that interesting like how does that make
the experience that much better so it
doesn't look like we're gonna find that
out I didn't think we would considering
that critic Scott four episodes they got
through this episode for their non
spoiler reviews I read some of those it
sounded like the mystery of who is in
Hale will continue but either way I
imagine this won't focus on her as much
since the last episode did I feel like
in the real world that Dolores will do
her bad
to make things uncomfortable and painful
for William after all we know how he
treated her in the park in the years
after that time they spent together so
there's definitely room for some stuff
to happen on that end of things I'm
curious to see what they want from Liam
since he doesn't have control over album
what they're trying to meet him at that
party for I'm hoping that we'll move
ahead somewhat now that Delores and
Caleb know each other and they're on the
same side I'd like to see that develop
as them finding out more about the
system and what her end game is as far
as trying to shut it down what that
looks like so I will end it there let me
know in the comments what you think what
are you excited about what do you think
about this idea of mirror worlds there
are quite a few mirrors in this trailer
who do you think's inhale do you care
who's inhale based on the candidates are
you hoping for a twist there we don't
see any Bernard in this episode so what
do you think he's at what's going on
with him thought we were gonna get this
buddy movie thing going on with him and
Stubbs and we don't see him at all here
so let me know in the comments please
like this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already thanks for watching I will talk
to you soon